[Music]
it is seven o'clock you're watching sky
news breakfast good to see you this
morning boris johnson look i think it's
fair to say he's already under a fair
amount of pressure from his own mps as
the way it goes on for the publication
of that report into downing street
parties
now it seems they also want the pm to
delay a hike in national insurance and
he might well be persuaded i'll be
speaking to the technology minister
chris philp shortly it is friday the
28th of january
hoping to break the diplomatic deadlock
talks are due between putin and macron
over the russia ukraine crisis as the
maid of kiev tells sky news ukrainians
are ready for any eventuality
we have to defend our country
depends our future defends our families
we are not aggressive we have to defend
taxing times talk of a government
rethink on raising national insurance as
the rise in the cost of living continues
to take hold
aid for afghanistan the foreign office
pledges nearly a hundred million pounds
of emergency funding for food health
care and water supplies
party on nightclubs in wales reopened
today as a wave of covert restrictions
on businesses are lifted
failure to deliver a warning of
communities left isolated as new
research shows post offices have been
closing at the rate of two a week for
the last two years
also ahead for you this morning
sightseeing booms in barnard castle and
it's for more than just eye tests we'll
be speaking to english heritage after
visitor numbers to the county durham
fortress soared in the last year
deliberately trying to scare me and
intimidate me and i'm going to do it
when you play my game slow it down break
it down
i'll be speaking to oscar nominee for
his ahmed about his new short film
and as for the weather after a mainly
fine start cloud will increase from the
west bringing rain and gales to northern
scotland
[Music]
morning all the united states is calling
on the un security council to discuss
the ongoing tensions on the russia
ukraine border russia has positioned a
hundred thousand troops near that border
but denies its plans to invade its
former soviet neighbour more talks among
european leaders are due this morning
with the french president emmanuel
macron due to speak to russia's vladimir
putin meanwhile ukrainians have been
preparing themselves
for every eventuality the mayor of kiev
and former world boxing champion vitaly
klitschko has told sky news his citizens
will defend themselves
now from the ukrainian capital kiev our
international affairs editor dominic
wakon sent this report
a school in kiev evacuated as bomb
disposal teams searched the building a
training exercise this time but schools
across ukraine have been plagued with
false alarm bomb scares being blamed on
russian agents
the ukrainians have obviously got to
carry out these kind of drills because
there could be more bomb scares but this
is doing nothing obviously to calm
already pretty jittery nerves in the
city
in the corridors of power in the offices
of the president his advisor told me a
russian invasion isn't imminent but
russian agents are inside the country
and creating division and fear
[Music]
from boris johnson yeah across town
kiev's mayor and boxing champion vitaly
klitschko showed me the book boris
johnson gave him the prince
machiavelli's manual on the dark arts of
power
has that been useful for you as mayor of
kiev yes of course
ukrainians he says will use everything
they have to defend themselves
we don't have another choice
we have to defend our country
defend our future defend our families
we are not aggressive we have to defend
the future of our children
but ukraine needs more help from allies
he says ridiculing germany's promise to
send 5 000 helmets and questioning what
side it's on
it's
it's joke german have to decide in which
side
if ukraine defend
our
independency intellectual integrity or
in the sight of aggressors
ukrainians must watch and wait while the
diplomacy goes on miles away from here
in the meantime preparing for the worst
dominic waghorn sky news kiev
joining us from the government this
morning the technology minister chris
philp minister great to have you on the
program this morning but clearly these
are these are very concerning times
given that the troop build up around
ukraine uh president biden has warned
ukraine's president to prepare for
impact are we really that close to
conflict in your opinion
well we're deeply concerned the build-up
of russian troops around the ukrainian
border has reached unprecedented levels
uh military units from the far east of
russia have moved into that region
something that hasn't happened for many
many years previously
so i think it is a very serious
situation i think president biden and
our prime minister are right to warn
president putin that the consequences if
they do uh invade ukraine will be very
very serious indeed for russia in terms
of sanctions
the americans made clear yesterday that
the nordstrom 2 pipe
would not happen if they invade
in the united kingdom we're doing
everything we can to support the
ukrainians including supplying uh
military equipment that would help them
and training as well that goes with that
that would help them prevent tanks
russian tanks from entering ukrainian
territory so i think we are urging uh
russia to
get to the table uh to discuss
issues that are relevant and to
de-escalate this situation which will
ultimately de-escalation is clearly in
the interests of all concerned uh it is
not too late to de-escalate and that is
what now needs to happen
yeah we will certainly see over there
the coming days and weeks that the tone
struck by vladimir putin and i do
however want to move on to more domestic
matters minister uh given we have you on
the program this morning
and national insurance in various
interviews this week ministers from the
cabinet down have all insisted that that
planned increase come april is going to
go ahead yesterday the prime minister
didn't confirm it i'm just wondering
what is your understanding of the
situation right now is that national
national insurance rise in april set in
stone
yes it is going ahead it was approved by
the whole cabinet it was passed by
parliament
with a significant
majority and the money is needed to fund
the nhs which is something i think that
is a national priority it's 36 billion
pounds over three years to fund the nhs
and social care
we need to put that money in to make
sure the nhs has the resources it needs
to recover after the pandemic and this
is a
proportionate way of finding that money
we are of course though all of this has
to be considered against the backdrop of
rising energy prices that
energy price cap
coming out in what just over a week's
time when are we going to hear more from
the government in this and your
colleague james heapey speaking on
television last night said the
government is in listening mode in all
of this when are we going to hear more
from the government about the financial
assistance that may be made available as
we we head into some very very expensive
times
yeah just on the national insurance
point it's worth keeping in mind that
the six and a half million people on the
lowest incomes won't pay a single extra
penny as a result of that and half of
the extra money paid will be paid by the
14 of top earners so it's just worth
keeping that in mind uh on your broader
question about cost of living uh yes the
government absolutely is in listening
mode about the general uh broader cost
of living issues there are lots of
measures in place already to help
address that i mean the cost of living
issue by the way is clearly a global
issue inflation in america is higher
than it is here it's higher in germany
than it is here as well it's a global
phenomenon but we do need to take action
so for example there is already
a big increase in the minimum wage
planned for april it's going up
to nine pounds 50 an hour an increase
that is well above the rate of inflation
we've already announced that the the
universal credit taper is being extended
which will put an extra thousand pounds
a year into the pockets of families on
uh lower income so all and there are a
huge number of interventions happening
on energy prices so for example uh
there's the the things like the winter
fuel allowance we've had for many years
there's also a half billion pound fund
established already to help people uh on
lower incomes with their fuel bills and
but i suspect there will be uh even more
uh done in the coming coming weeks and
months but in a targeted way to make
sure people who need some assistance
with things like fuel bills um can get
that but a lot has been done already
i i wonder if we can turn our attention
to afghanistan you may well have heard
us reporting the fact that the foreign
office is giving an additional hundred
million pounds aid which i'm sure those
in afghanistan will be crying out for
but but yesterday the accusation was
made that the prime minister was
ultimately responsible for signing off
on the repatriation of of animals over
afghans he described
that allegation yesterday
as total rhubarb
what on earth did he mean by that
well i think he meant that the
allegation was not true and that's what
he meant when he said why because the
prime minister wasn't involved in well i
think he wasn't involved in making uh
individual uh decisions and uh you know
we should also be clear by the way um
that the plane which those people and
animals came out on was not a plane that
was commissioned or chartered by the uk
government it was done privately by by
donors but i think the prime minister's
made his uh position on this very clear
it wasn't something that he was
personally involved in
because i keep hearing that the prime
minister is gifted in its use i'm just
wondering whether or not you think
describing it as total rhubarb is is
respectful to the afghan interpreters
that we left behind some of whom are now
dead
well i think what we should be clear
about in terms of the afghan situation
is that last august in that emergency
situation the united kingdom evacuated
far more people from afghanistan than
any other european country we did it in
very short order we provided troops on
the ground to protect that air base in
kabul so i think we can be extremely
proud of what we did in afghanistan and
now we're running a program over a
five-year period that will see more
at-risk afghan civilians including or
particularly women and girls resettled
into the uk in large 20 000 people that
again that is more than any other
european country so the fact the united
kingdom has helped and will help okay
more afghans than any other european
country is something we can be
enormously proud of
yeah i i understand that but despite the
fact that we have emails from the
foreign office letters from
boris johnson's then pps the prime
minister describes the allegation that
he authorized this as as total i'll
repeat that so if the prime minister
didn't authorize it who did
well he was the prime minister wasn't
involved in making operational decisions
the plane as i said was actually charted
privately in terms of the
operational decision making about who
had access to the uh the airstrip the
airfield and who got into the perimeter
of it and those would have been
operational decisions i don't know
exactly which person would have been
controlling that on a day-to-day basis
the ministry of defense
well they were working on they were
working on that together both of those
departments but let me just be clear
again the united kingdom evacuated more
people from afghanistan in august and
any other european country and we can be
extremely proud of that
i i understand that but if the prime
minister is telling us despite the
evidence that we can all see with her
own eyes where he is named in an email
from the foreign office as having
authorized this if he didn't authorize
it who did
i think it's a fairly significant
question
i've explained already that those
operational decisions about um on the
ground were being taken by
teams working in the foreign office
operationally the ministry of defense
obviously were uh in control with the
americans of kabul airport the prime
minister's been clear that it wasn't the
decision he was involved in uh i think
whoever wrote that email it was
obviously a sort of second or third hand
account clearly it was um mistaken and
as i say the efforts we made in
afghanistan in august and that we're
making now over the next now and over
the next few years
are leading europe and that is something
we should be proud of
minister i suppose the point the broader
point in all of this is that there are
legitimate concerns about the prime
minister's capacity for telling the
truth at the moment of his moral probity
in fact you yourself were openly mocked
by the audience and on bbc's any
questions when the host asks you if
boris johnson was a beacon of moral
integrity i mean do you stand by that do
you honestly believe mr johnson to be a
beacon of moral integrity
yeah yes i do and i said he's someone
who is working night and day and has
been since he became prime minister two
and a half years ago
to he's delivered brexit which obviously
people thought was difficult or
impossible he did that he won a
landslide general election victory uh
we've since been hit by covid and he and
his team have been working night and day
to get us through this pandemic as a
result of which we've had a world a
european leading
booster program uh we've got more
payroll jobs now 400 000 more than
before the pandemic youth unemployment
at a record low the imf came out this
week forecasting that we would have the
highest growth in this country of any g7
country of any g7 economy none of that
is an accident it's happened as a result
of enormous amounts of hard work that
have been led by the prime minister and
i think the results uh speak louder than
words and the results the prime minister
has delivered for this country in
extraordinarily difficult circumstances
are something that he and his team the
government and frankly all of us can be
proud of
just just finally and very very briefly
i do need to let you go um as of this
moment as of quarter past seven uh on a
friday morning the sue gray report has
not yet been handed to downing street is
that your understanding
well i spoke to someone in downing
street uh about half an hour ago and
they certainly didn't indicate that it
had been received so uh i i you know i
don't know a lot more than you do but
i've certainly got no information as of
right now that it's been received
yes phil thanks very much for joining us
this morning appreciate it
thank you
time for us to take a quick look at the
front pages and let's start with the i
which is reporting that boris johnson's
plan to tackle the cost of living crisis
is being delayed by what it calls the
turmoil in downing street
treasury alarm says the guardian as the
prime minister refuses to confirm
whether the national insurance rise
would go ahead as planned in april we
had the minister just a moment ago
saying that it would uh the guardian
however interpreting all this is an
attempt to save his job
the telegraph understands that the
treasury intends to close a loophole
which allowed people to claim a tax
credit of 125 pounds if they work from
home even for a single day
still to come on the program this
morning we'll have much more on the cost
of living crisis scotland's shadow
scotland sorry labour's shadow of
scotland secretary ian murray on the
program as the party calls for action
from westminster and indeed hollywood on
rising
two weeks after the devastating volcanic
eruption and tsunami we'll hear from
tonga's high commissioner about the
current situation
and i'll be speaking to the head of a
charity calling for more mental health
support for nhs
staff
well the foreign secretary has announced
a further 97 million pounds of emergency
aid to help tackle afghanistan's
humanitarian crisis it comes after
reports from sky news
that some families are selling their
kidneys to pay for food
well the correspondent responsible for
that story our special correspondent
alex crawford joins us now live from
hera alex really good to see you this
morning and 97 million pounds i mean
it's it's not a drop in the ocean of
course that money will find a home i'm
sure but the scale of the problems that
you've been witnessing suggests
there needs to be a degree more
humanitarian and intervention
as you say of course people will welcome
something because at the moment
millions literally millions are not
getting anything out of a population of
say around about 40 million maybe give
or take a a few
almost 90 percent more than 90 percent
are not
getting very much at all and this is a
country that's been pretty much wholly
dependent on international aid for the
best part of two decades so it's a
sudden cutting off of that aid is really
hitting hard and we're seeing on the
ground
the desperation i mean it can't really
be exaggerated too much there are
children women men all hungry almost
everyone we meet pretty everyone we meet
out from elders to the very young and
the very small are all hungry and all
begging us to help them and to to find
food for them they're earning at maximum
if anything many families are not
earning anything and there's a real
problem with getting access to aid so
even if the aid is is uh doubled as the
british government is saying they're
they're doubling their their aid
increases a lot of it isn't getting to
the right people and there definitely
isn't enough of it
alex you and the team do stay safe and
well for now thanks very much indeed
now reports suggest the prime minister
could be reconsidering the hike in
national insurance as he faces pressure
from some of his mps not to raise the
tax as people face a cost of living
crisis
ministers are due to meet next week to
discuss the situation as many struggle
to pay for essentials skies shaman
freeman powell reports
to buy a loaf of bread single mom emma
may visit four or five different shops
she learned that the only way to compete
with rising food prices is to shop
around for a deal
it is quite an effort to go through it
once you've done it a few times you do
get into swinging it and you know which
place to go because i find that you need
to
find the consistent price as opposed to
an offer price
families across the uk are facing the
worst living crisis for 30 years
millions can't even afford the basics
and single parents like emma are even
more likely to feel the pinch
campaigner jack monroe took to twitter
to criticize the current model used to
measure the average cost of goods
saying it doesn't reflect the impact
that pricier food is having on poorer
families
lorna cooper has been giving advice to
low-income families for years now
and says demand for her help has only
grown when i first started my facebook
page like seven years ago we would get
people messaging and saying i'm really
struggling this month you know there was
an expense and it was a short term
but now it's not a short term it's every
single week every single month people
just don't have enough
to fulfill their basic needs
with bills food and fuel costs rising
families up and down the country worry
they may not be able to feed their kids
charities say that this reality is even
worse for those dependent on the state
for help i would say to the government
you really need to write to increase
benefits by the rate of inflation at
least the rate of inflation because you
know without that single parents just
running to stay still but whilst waiting
for those in power to help
many in britain will find themselves
falling below the bread line
shimon freeman powell sky news
some of the days other news now and a
covered restrictions in wales are being
eased from today
nightclubs can reopen while social
distancing and the rule of six have been
scrapped for outdoor hospitality
self-isolation has also been cut to five
full days bringing in it in line with
england but masks will still be required
in most indoor settings and covered
passes needed for large events
well the latest uk data shows 102
292 new cases of coronavirus confirmed
in the latest 24 hours another 346
deaths were recorded taking the number
of deaths within 28 days of a positive
test to 154
702.
scientists are warning that allowing
poorer countries to remain unvaccinated
against coronavirus is a reckless
approach to public health a letter
signed by more than 300 health experts
including members of the government's
sage committee says the best way to
prevent new variants is to vaccinate
most of the world's population
more than 200 post offices have closed
in the past two years the equivalent
of two a week research by citizens
advice also found half of all
temporarily closed branches have been
shut for more than two years let's get
more in this story our correspondent
molina veselinovich is in the newsroom
at morning milan i mean it's been bad
for quite some time if you've been
trying to find a post office but i
suppose these figures just seem to
confirm that
morning neil that's right and there are
still communities in this country who
rely on the post office to carry out
some pretty essential tasks like paying
the bills and
sending letters and citizens advice
found that they're now spending a lot
more time and money trying to reach a
branch more than 200 branches closed in
the last two years and in rural areas
one in three branches are open only
about five and a half hours a week and
this does disproportionately affect
people who are older who are disabled
those in rural communities who still use
these services because of course a lot
of them have actually moved online
people are paying by direct debit
they're sending emails but not everyone
and citizens advise quoted one man in
their research who had a 19-minute trip
to his closest post office he could only
afford to go once a week so he would
collate all of his bills and letters for
that once weekly trip but that would
mean he would sometimes be late with his
bills and he got fined by utility
companies and then another woman moved
away when her local branch was closed
because she couldn't afford to get to
the other nearest one but the other one
got closed as well so for those people
it's a dire situation in turn the post
office says that their branches have
been stabled they've got 11 500 outlets
across the country and they also say
that in 2019 alone they opened 200 new
ones
malaya thank you
let's take a look at a few of the day's
other headlines now and a teenager has
been charged with two counts of racially
aggravated assault
after two jewish men were attacked
outside their shop in north london
malachi thought is due to appear at
highbury corner magistrates court later
today
the national cyber security center has
urged uk organizations to bolster their
cyber security amidst concern for
potential russian attacks linked to
tensions with ukraine
the warning comes as ukraine was hit
with what officials described as a
massive cyber attack last week that
targeted around 70 government websites
it became famous overnight after dominic
cummings lockdown visit and now barnard
castle has seen its busiest year on
record
english heritage said visitor numbers to
the medieval castle were up a fifth on
pre-pandemic levels
british sign language is set to become a
recognized language in the uk
the government's due to back a bill that
would improve accessibility for deaf
people including the use of sign
language during public service
announcements
the rspb's annual garden wildlife survey
starts today the conservation charity is
asking bird watchers to put out fresh
water clean bird feeders and a variety
of food to attract different species to
their gardens
hundreds of thousands of people are
expected to take part by recording how
many species they spot within an hour
welcome back just a reminder as to our
top stories this hour
the french president emmanuel macron is
expected to speak with his russian
counterpart vladimir putin this morning
as the u.s president warns there is a
distinct possibility that russia could
invade ukraine
over restrictions are being eased in
wales from today with self-isolation
cuts to a minimum five days and the
relaxing of social distancing
and the technology minister confirmed
that the national insurance tax rise is
going ahead in april as the rise in the
cost of living continues to take
hold
well let's just have a quick reminder as
to what the minister told me just a few
minutes ago
yes it is going ahead it was approved by
the whole cabinet it was passed by
parliament
with a significant
majority and the money is needed to fund
the nhs which is something i think that
is a national priority it's 36 billion
pounds over three years to fund the nhs
and social care we need to put that
money in to make sure the nhs has the
resources it needs to recover after the
pandemic and this is a
proportionate way of finding that money
yes the government absolutely is in
listening mode about the general uh
broader cost of living issues there are
lots of measures in place already to
help address that i mean the cost of
living issue by the way is clearly a
global issue inflation in america is
higher than it is here it's higher in
germany than it is here as well it's a
global phenomenon but we do need to take
action
let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell morning rob um
yeah so national insurance rise in april
definitely happening then yeah yeah
there's a sort of mismatch though
between what ministers like chris philp
are saying and even the number 10
spokesperson who gives the regular lobby
briefing uh ask that straight question
gives a straight answer yes it's
happening
when it comes to the prime minister
though he's had multiple opportunities
this week where he's been asked that
exact same question and he's just not
willing to be as explicit as saying yes
that national insurance rise one and a
quarter per cent for uh employees one
and a quarter percent for employers
that's due in april is going ahead he
just says look we need to find the money
the nhs needs the money but then pressed
on whether that will come through ni uh
he just won't say yes or can't seemingly
bring himself to say yes
i think that combined with um a few uh
well-placed anonymous quotes in some of
the newspapers this week is why many are
wondering um whether
this could be something that could
either be
put on hold or shelved
partly to ease cost of living we know
energy bills will be going up that
announcement's due in about 10 days on
the price cap inflation running high is
it politically feasible for them to be
putting up taxes at that point but also
you can't disentangle it all of this
from the other situation that the prime
minister is in over the sugray report
which we are still waiting for it's
still not gone to number 10 um as of
this morning and this could be something
delaying this tax rise that many of his
mps hate that might get them on side if
he did it it would be a big call though
and he'd probably have a fight with the
treasury if he decided to do it i think
so rob for now thank you
it is now two weeks since the volcanic
eruption that triggered the tsunami that
devastated parts of tonga relief efforts
are underway as aids from around the
world has started to arrive
tonga's high commissioner
joins us now on the program titulupe
fenetopova vow tui vacano um excellence
with many many apologies for butchering
uh your beautiful name there i wonder if
we can start though with just an update
of what is going on on the ground in
tonga at the moment as i understand it
some 85 of the country was affected by
the tsunami
yes well thank you very much for having
me and good morning we're still very
much at the recovery phase so at least
at this time we don't have a lot of
figures on the extent of the damage
caused by the eruption of the underwater
volcano and the tsunami but we do know
that 85 of the population was severely
affected
communication is still very much
intermittent
transportation between the islands is a
challenge
food and water is a scarcity although we
are we have recovered we have received
humanitarian aid and supplies while
trying to maintain our copic-free status
what level of assistance have you have
you been getting from from regional
partners and indeed from countries
slightly further afield
yes well we're grateful for the
outpouring of the support that we've
received from our partners and from
people around the world a number of our
committed partners the uk included as
well as australia japan new zealand fiji
the us
india and france and others have sprung
to action with the provision of
humanitarian assistance and aid in form
of food water
and shelter
and uh also with some technical
assistance as well
what then is the priority for tonga at
the moment we understand of course there
are problems with the contamination of
drinking water i mean that that would
strike me as as one of the priorities
but you're closer to the situation on
the ground where are the pressure where
is the pressure most being felt
currently
our priority needs would be food and a
clean water supply but also to
re-establish the communications with the
outer islands as well as abroad medicine
would also be a priority meet as a
result of the volcanic eruption where
the ash still remains
in most of tonga causing a lot of dust
uh and of course uh as part of the
commonwealth her majesty has even sent a
message to the people of tonga has it
has it perhaps been
if not surprising then reassuring the
outpouring of international
sympathy that there has been
yes we were grateful to receive and to
see the the message from her majesty the
queen and uh she basically had offered
her support and her condolences to his
majesty the king and the people of tonga
so we were very grateful for that
of course as you say the situation is
still being appraised and there are
communications difficulties on the
ground but but in terms of building back
from this how confident are you that
tonga can do so perhaps with the
assistance of the international
community
yes um as i said before a number of our
committed partners have sprung into
action to help the people of tama with
the humanitarian relief this will be a
long road to recovery
and we hope that our partners remain
with us as we seek to rebuild
the nation smarter and more resilient
um excellency just for for viewers who
are not as familiar as as perhaps some
of us are with tonga and as as someone
who's you know supported rugby and
played rugby a lot through his life that
was my kind of initial point of contact
uh with the islands just tell us just a
little bit about your coleman and why it
is such a special place
well
tonga is the only constitutional
monarchy in the south pacific
and uh we've survived years and years of
of of being independent and having a
policy a foreign policy of being friends
to all and enemies of none
and uh we've uh we've
we've uh we have no winter we it's all
sun sand and sea
and uh we're very welcome to uh to
tourists and the tourist tourism
industry uh contributes it makes a huge
huge part of our um makes up a huge part
of our industry our economy yes
well i have to say it is a place that i
desperately want to visit at some point
in the very near future um your
excellency thank you so much for joining
us in the program really appreciate your
time
thank you very much for having me
now the last two years of the covert
pandemic have taken their toll on many
people but perhaps most acutely on those
who work in the health service a recent
survey of 10 000 nhs staff found that
half
are actively looking to leave their job
with two-thirds citing poor mental
health as the main factor
dame claire gerard is the president of
the royal college of general
practitioners and chair of doctors in
distress great to see you on the program
um this morning
how concerned should we be
about the long-term impact on on the
mental health of our health
practitioners
thank you and good morning
listen it's difficult to answer that
because of course anybody with that's
got mental health issues because of the
work their work is is worrying and the
figures that we're seeing from the
surveys but also from a service i run
for doctors with mental illness is
showing that we're seeing a staggering
increase in the number of people
presenting with mental health problems
and what doctors in distress has been
doing over the pandemic is providing
support groups for doctors nurses
paramedics in fact for any healthcare
staff and
we're actually calling on the government
to fund for every single healthcare
worker just one hour per month to help
workers remain resilient remain mentally
well by providing them with one hour per
month for supervision support we can
call it what we like in order that we
can actually keep people well and keep
people in the workplace
and of course staff retention within the
health service was an issue even before
we went into the pandemic i mean when
we're talking about you know perhaps as
many as one in ten posts within the
health service uh vacant at the moment
any any further exodus of staff from the
front line of the nhs
really does start to put the quality of
care into question
yes and to be fair the nhs has provided
support for staff throughout the
pandemic and what the pandemic has done
is shown a light on how important mental
health and
mental well-being is but what we're
asking for is that you don't have to put
your hand up and say i'm struggling i
need help because those that need the
help most are the most reluctant we want
this to be embedded within every single
health workers contract
paid for time allocated to it so it's
there and it becomes as normalized as
for example i have to do continuing
professional development quite rightly
and this becomes as normalized and
yes i mean we've seen the pandemic has
taken its toll on everybody i think
most people are feeling in not as
resilient and as mentally well as they
were say before the pandemic but
healthcare staff have had to carry
really quite an enormous burden of the
the work of keeping us all well and
keeping us as safe as possible
i mean it strikes me that even
pre-pandemic working in the health
service working in health care is
probably not one of the least stressful
at least stressful uh professions so i'm
wondering to what extent when people are
training when people are perhaps doing
their kind of their clinical part of
their training to what extent are they
briefed are they warned are they
prepared for the mental stresses of of
working within the health service
it doesn't form certainly part of of
didn't form part of my training i don't
think it forms part of a medical
student's training i think there is an
increased awareness but listen nothing
can prepare you for the fear the anxiety
of actually having to deal with sick
people and it is an anxiety provoking uh
place to work but that's why we train
that's why we have such a long training
but what we're calling for just as we've
had
physical personal protective equipment
during the pandemic i think we now need
psychological ppe we need to make sure
that we start to look after protect
support all nhs staff because
we've just seen the figures on
recruitment and retention and it's so
important that we start somewhere and
actually providing every single health
worker with a space and time to reflect
to be together to come together it's
sort of bombed or obvious and most
people think well doesn't this happen
anyway if you're a nurse and you're
having to deal with a award and patient
dying or you're a pediatrician and
having to tell parents that baby's very
very unsick that there aren't spaces
where we can talk about that but there
isn't and what we're calling for is that
this becomes part and parcel of our
contractual arrangement that it's there
for us to to pick up without having to
ask for it
psychological ppe that's a great phrase
and one which i am about to steal uh
dame claire gerard thank you so much for
joining us this morning appreciate your
time thank you and thank you for all
your hard work as well
oh cheers
i'll take that
thank you
welcome back
covered restrictions in wales are being
eased from today nightclubs can reopen
while social distancing and the rule of
six have been scrapped for outdoor or
hospitality self-isolation rules are
also being brought in line with those in
england joining us now the welsh economy
minister i'm getting mr great to have
you on the program this morning um
shall we start with with with covert
isolation uh bringing it down to up to a
minimum of five days coming in line with
that in england and northern ireland
were you perhaps isolating for too long
before now
well we were waiting for the up-to-date
advice from public health whales so the
health minister had advice that came in
recently that came to the chief medical
officer we discussed it in cabinet just
last week actually that the advice was
imminent that advice has now come
through and we made
an announcement so it's acting on the
advice that we have look at the date and
the evidence we have and that's why
we've made the decision so it's five
full days with a negative test on day
five and then a negative test on day six
which is common with the rest of the uk
so uh from friday uh nightclub set to
reopen the numbers limited the rules
limiting numbers gathering in pubs and
restaurants scrapped social distancing
comes to an end and all just in time for
the for the six nations can you can you
give us an idea of just how badly
hospitality has been hit in wales as a
result of the restrictions
i've had direct conversations with
people in hospitality the visitor
economy and i know it's been very very
difficult for them
and the difficulties of course england
took a very different approach
we had advice very clear public health
advice that we needed to act and that's
why we did so i know that some people
have been fearful for their businesses
been worried about whether this really
would come to an end as quickly as we
said it was likely to and i think
actually a few weeks ago hospitality
we're expecting that the restrictions
would carry on further than they are now
because of the response of people in
wales or to bring those restrictions to
an end then interestingly i think
there's a good deal more optimism in the
sector they're looking forward to
trading but the economic support we
provided the financial support we're
actually encouraging people to take it
up because we haven't seen them take it
we thought we would do which is i think
because people are looking forward to
training and just want to get on with it
so i'm optimistic about the future we
make great efforts to get to this place
and as a result of all of our heads
fewer people have come to harm they're
gonna have more optimism at staying out
of restrictions and further measures in
the future
what though of the of those methods by
which the the welsh approach to dealing
with covid now does actually
differentiate from that in england face
masks and and covered passes do those
remain under review or or do you perhaps
see those as
being necessary for longer than just
another few weeks no we review all of
our measures on a three weekly cycle so
actually the next time we're reviewing
everything is on the 10th of february
and we'll continue to review measures
every three weeks to see if they're
still necessary or proportionate so you
will still need to wear a face covering
if you're going into a shop or going on
to public transport for example that is
that is different to england we still
think that's the right thing covered
rates in wales are about 500 and 100 000
so not low but actually that's nearly
half of the rates in england and i think
that just highlights a very different
risk appetite between ministers
looking at the public health advice and
whether it's the right thing to do now
these quite like touch measures but we
think they still matter and make a
difference to keep people safe and keep
all of this activity out
some some however might not describe
covered passes as as in any way light
touch just just in terms of the kind of
the
philosophical underpinning of the policy
i mean is it your intention to remove
the requirement for covert passes at
some point in the future
yes i'm very keen that we move to a
position where we don't have any
measures or restrictions in place
but what we need to do is to take those
steps
at a proportion of time it's why we take
seriously the public health advice the
scientific advice we get we have a
review on the 10th of february
if we still have the same measures then
we'll review all the most again
in three weeks time after that so it's
regular review and i can assure you
ministers in the world should not very
keen not to have to talk about
additional measures and protections in
place to reduce the harmful coverage and
to get on with the business of
rebuilding the welsh economy
we have significant challenges not just
pandemic recovery new relationships with
europe but also new opportunities i
think as well so i'm much keener to come
back on this program so about what we're
doing to rebuild jobs and prosperity
here in wales von gething great to have
you on the program thanks for joining us
thank you